moi j'arrive pas forcément à leur rendre
les gens heureux j'essaye de l'est de
les soulager de leurs maladies mais
j'arrive pas à les rendre heureux et
particulièrement quand ya eu les
histoires du coc vide les gens ils
étaient prises tous mes pleins qui avait
envie de changer de vie changer de ville
des ruptures même conjugale est en fait
il était malheureux et puis je me suis
rendu compte qu'au fond en changeant des
petites choses du quotidien pardon
d'emprunter mogil en changeant des
choses du quotidien on peut arriver à
être plus heureux le bonheur c'est super
un parent ça envoie les petites choses
et on attend mais d'abord le bonheur
c'est plus important il ya eu une étude
vraiment sérieuse sur plus de 80000
personnes qui a montré que l'optimisme
et le bonheur permettait aux gens de
vivre plus vieux ils ont interrogé des
nonagénaires des gens qui avaient plus
de 90 ans ils ont constaté la différence
hier que plus vous êtes heureux pelouse
est bien heureux et plus d'être
optimistes et plus vous vivrez c'est sûr
que c'est quoi votre secret pour être
beau paul tube de bonheur vous pour être
bon sur quatre bonnes heures oui le
sport ah oui c'est vrai mais castaldi en
fait partie moi sur les femmes bien sûr
mais ouais c'est vrai c'est moi j'ai un
secret mais aussi d'argent et quoi quoi
moi
ça dure ou non s'il faut à tous ces faux
nom moi c'est son nom mais je vais dire
tu peux dire je prends le métro obligées
à le dire je mange énormément de quality
street
la boîte à bonheur
c'est vrai mais c'est le sport moi c'est
le sport franchement c'est le sport et
le chocolat il ya eu un truc très
marrant l'étude qui a porté sur le
chocolat elle racontait que le chocolat
c'est un aliment qui donne du bonheur
voilà est en fait il rajouté dans
l'étude sauf que ils ont vérifié ils ont
pris deux groupes différents il rajoute
du bonheur sauf si vous culpabiliser ça
veut dire qu il faut manger quand vous
demandez lui avec sonneurs mais comme tu
parlais de faire du sport il ya des
études qui ont été faites pour mesurer
il ya des indices du bonheur ça veut
dire on est capable de mesurer sur une
échelle comme pour la douleur 'l'indice
de bonheur des gens ils ont remarqué que
les gens qui étaient actifs physiquement
il était plus heureux et donc tous ces
gens ce qui était pendant le coc vide un
peu tristoune etc on leur dit plein de
choses comme ça on leur dit qu'on va
commencer à avoir une activité physique
change et l'aménagement de chez vous
vous souvenez pendant le comice et s'ils
l'ont fait ils ont rangé leur maison
pourquoi on sa maison ils ont modifié
leur maison progressivement alors tu dis
il ya quatre domaines l'alimentation la
forme physique le psychisme et
l'environnement c'est ça alors
l'alimentation doit faire quoi
l'alimentation il ya deux choses d'abord
retrouver le plaisir de manger arrêter
avec toutes les injonctions qu'on allait
trouver mentaires on peut manger
sainement jours sans être obligé
d'écouter d'être flipper combien de
parents j'ai mon fils ne mangent pas de
légumes etc bon écoute et faites vous
plaisir en mangeant si la première
fonction de manger c'est se faire
plaisir après les autres fonctions mais
on a retrouvé un peu des classiques ça
veut dire les gens qui mangeaient des
légumes les étudiants qui manger des
légumes étaient plus créatifs et plus
heureux que les autres les gens du rien
manger plus de légumes ne
s'était pas la même chose que les
cantons me donnent la consigne de manger
des légumes pour avoir déçu la mine
ensuite on a découvert que effectivement
quand on mangeait des probiotiques les
gens qui mangeaient beaucoup de produits
il était plus heureux donc y avez vous
avez pour la chose sur l'alimentation
comment les produits laitiers sont nos
amis pour la vie je le sais moi je kiffe
est remonté à fermenter
formidable le chou fermenté ouais alors
qu'elle mais tu es du soudan à vocale ah
oui ça est un petit peu de dos de celle
de ça et va fermenter ouais c'est très
très activement satwa pas oui bien sûr
ah ouais et sa superbe et bien non il ya
vacance
gastrique masse et miguel quant à moi
toi moi je n'avais seraient
alors lui se ferment devant sa porte
c'est très bon c'est vrai mais s'il vous
plaît bon on n'est pas là pour parler de
chou fermenté c'est bon oui alors donc
et psychologiquement c'est de ces noirs
s'y essayer de réfréner l'agressivité
qu'on ressent à l'égard des joueurs
allez par grèce mais c'est très bien
merci désolé pardon je t'aime ah oui
j'aurais fait délai pour voir je vois à
léonard voilà
mon livre également à les quatre
commerces non mais c'est le répéter en
boucle obama répète lui bah tu me dois
donc lancé ça
c'est à dire que c'est une philosophie
de la loi comme on dit avec ce 4 phrase
j'ai noté c'est à dire merci pardon je
suis désolé et également je vous aime
avec ses 4 ans qui sont répétés comme
une intonation aurait été il arrive à
recréer du bonheur chez les gens
évidemment c'est pas la peine de prendre
des médicaments ça veut dire que quand
on applique tous ces petits conseils
quand on refait marché les gens au
quotidien quand on leur apprend à
cuisiner en disant mais cuisinier c'est
méditer ces méditer c'est à dire tout le
monde l'a cuisiné pendant confinement il
était à braquer sur lignac ouais je
mélange les oignons avec live méditer
c'est important éditeur modifier sa
maison pour avoir un habitat qui soit
convenable c'est à dire changer un peu
les couleurs de chez soi l'habillement
quand vous êtes malheureux qu'est ce que
vous faites quand vous êtes malheureux
s'arrêter au regard des huiles à une vie
de chien
quand vous êtes malheureux g1 vous
habiller pas bien
et moi je me souviens la nièvre s'est
malheureusement
un
moment de notre vie cyril une de mes
filles a eu un gros problème dans la vie
et ma femme lui avait dit un truc génial
l'e10 au moment où tu as ce très gros
problème ne te laisse pas aller ça veut
dire habito après ce qu on sort mieux
que d'habitude pour te donner l'illusion
dans le miroir que tu te portent mieux
que tout va bien et c est ça va t'aider
à être heureuse et je l'avais trouvé
absolument intelligente je n'embrasse
d'ailleurs c'est ta femme oui c'est ma
femme est
pour vous parce que vous êtes
formidables mais karl lagerfeld disait
celui qui s'habille en jogging a
abandonné sa vie ah ouais et ben moi et
moi je suis dit celui qui est celui qui
s'habille en jogging ton merde
[Applaudissements]
il ya une autre à 30 pour lui ce qu'il
disait c'est pas l'habit qui fait la
mode c'est le style qui fait la mode
comment tu portes le djia les joggings
élégant voilà merci jean michel
heureusement que tu es là
dernière petite chose c'est vrai que tu
dis qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire vraiment au niveau au niveau des
animaux c'est quoi le matin l'après midi
et soir c'est quoi légumes d'abord faut
arrêter avec les consignes qu'on a reçus
pendant longtemps on entend tout le
temps les gens avaient les mêmes bêtises
le petit déjeuner le meilleur état de la
journée c'est un slogan c'est pas vrai
parce que de manger à l'horaire que vous
avez envie de manger ou santé avoir faim
les gens il est midi ce fonctionne avec
une petite routine il est midi s'arrange
étapes afin manger à l'heure où vous
avez envie de manger manger des choses
qui vous font envie
la nuit
n'était pas contraint par un horaire
salaire il ya des gens qui mangent
absolument à la même suis absolument pas
ça vous n'avez pas envie de petit
déjeuner vous aurez peut-être envie de
grignoter vers 10h un truc correct et en
même temps dans l'alimentation n'a
retrouvé toujours mêmes trucs les oméga
3 les poissons gras sur les légumes mais
surtour prenez du plaisir avec les
choses il ya plein de gens qui mangent
en pensant ça ils mangent plus pour
manger ne mangeant pas c'est mon métier
c'est la nutrition j'ai toujours assez
ça et depuis 40 ans canton il vaut mieux
dire prends tu encourages depuis 30 ans
depuis 30 ans j'essaye de faire
comprendre aux gens que la première
fonction de la nourriture c'est de se
faire plaisir voilà et après manger
sainement mais ne mangeait pas
arithmétiquement sa marque et son chef
oui bonsoir moi j'avais un basset c'est
un chien héros site web j'avais laissé
passer devant lui permet pas d'en contre
millions d'amis la non vous n'êtes pas
vtt un an mais j'expliquais et y avait
des études américaines qui avaient dit
si vous laissez tout le temps sa gamelle
plein en fait il va il va s'auto réguler
mangera quand il a faim il arrêtera il
arrêtera et ça va ça est en fait il est
fini en baise il est mort
m
ça n'a pas marché qu'il est bien calé au
moment où ça
devrait bouger au moment mais bien sûr
mais c'est parce que tu lui donnait à
manger c'est de ton chien s'est apprécié
après sa mort que j'avais eu l'idée de
wakfu
l'américain encore une étude américaine
à la con ça la régularité que les
américaines